all right what's going on guys this is
rob and if you talk to anybody out there
who has been reading dc comics for well
really since the 90s and you asked them
what would you say the top five comic
book stories are from dc comics i
guarantee you somewhere in that list
will be kingdom come and rightfully so
kingdom come is one of the greatest
stories ever written by dc comics right
it's written by mark wade and it's drawn
by alex ross for those of you guys who
are curious about the artist alex ross
is kind of like the premier comic book
artist the definitive guy doesn't really
draw comics as much as he used to this
guy was where it was at and this story
is kind of like the definitive dc story
for a variety of reasons so the reason
we're covering this is one i'm gonna be
on a cruise for the next week and a half
or so and two because we're covering uh
dark crisis infinite frontier and this
is one of the worlds they landed on and
instead of just kind of giving you guys
some sort of ad hoc explanation i
figured we would actually remaster the
kingdom come series we did before and
bring it to you here so you can
basically see what this story is about
and why it's such a big deal they landed
here so the way the kingdom come opens
up is it's really kind of given to us by
a quote now while this story does deal
with like what is essentially a
superhero or a superhuman civil war in
dc comics really more of like a civil
war event before marvel civil war it's
also just as much a religious story it's
not really on the nose or anything like
that like the god of abraham will save
us but it's one of those things where
there's a lot of religious underpinnings
and kind of like armageddon-esque
scenarios and and really just kind of an
overall feel that goes with it so what
we get here is we're told and there
followed hail and fire mingled with
blood there fell a great star from the
heaven burning as if it were a lamp and
i beheld and heard an angel saying with
a loud voice woe woe woe to the
inhabiters of the earth and what you end
up getting here is this kind of moment
where you basically have norman mckay
who is reading from the book of
revelation to wesley dots now this
moment here is highly important and it's
really the most significant if you
understand the history of wesley dodd so
in dc comics way back in the 1980s well
technically 1989 so really like the late
1980s with sandman volume 2 issue number
one we were introduced to a character
that you've all probably heard of called
dream of the endless and the way this
worked is that there came a point in
time where in the dc continuity itself
back in the 1930s dream of the endless
had basically been trapped on earth
right literally had his crystal taken
away from him and all kinds of stuff but
regardless he was stuck on earth and the
result was that it wreaked havoc across
the earth itself in the sense that if if
dream of the endless is captured people
can't dream properly their sleep doesn't
work the way it's supposed to so what
you had were all these people across the
world that were experiencing bouts of
insomnia or they were just sleeping
continually or they were having like
waking dreams or basically they were
awake but they weren't really there they
were just dreaming all the time wesley
dodds is one of those guys the big
difference here is that wesley dodds had
a lot of prophetic dreams so he was
essentially dreaming of the future
different things along those lines what
kingdom come does and what's so cool
about this is this story was written
back before you had the new 52 and what
that means is this takes place during
what was called new earth basically the
continuity that came after the events of
crisis on infinite earth so there's only
one universe here and the reason why
that matters is because when it came to
new earth in guys like wesley dodds
while he did technically get a new
origin a lot of it was pretty intact
with the way he existed way back before
the events of crisis on infinitives and
the way this story is told it really
kind of harkens back to the heroes of
yesteryear so while technically this is
post-crisis in a lot of ways it feels
like they're referencing the age of
superheroes from the golden age of
comics from the 1940s in dc's publishing
history it's one of the reasons why i
love it so much right because alex ross
art always remind me of an era or a time
when superheroes stood a little bit
taller and walked a little more
confidently and there was no ambiguity
determining the difference between the
good guys and the bad guys the good guys
fought the bad guys and the day was
saved and that was it there was no such
thing as anti-heroes or anything like
that the waters weren't murky but the
reality here is that wesley dodds even
growing into his old age had seemingly
never lost the power of dream of the
endless and so what that means is that
what he's experiencing right now are
these visions and he even tells norman
mckay seven thunders will utter their
voices and it was given unto him to make
war with the saints babylon falls norman
be the one who listens to me and this is
why it's important is because the way
this is presented to us is that wesley
dodds is considered to be a kook he's
considered to be a crazy person right
these visions of the end times and the
apocalypse coming and everything's going
to die and come to an end right all that
kind of stuff nobody really takes him
seriously and he can't convince anybody
that these dreams that he's having are
legitimate dreams and even in the old
sandman stories right the old wesley
dodd comics that in a lot of ways it was
kind of the question is this guy really
insane but you really saw dc sort of
toying with the idea that maybe he
really was crazy and so it was really
cool because in order to basically calm
him down right in order to calm him down
and to keep him or get him back to her
normal state he tells norman mckay you
have to read right you have to read from
the book now eventually wesley dodds
passes on and this is when norman mckay
basically gives us a kind of tour of
what the world looks like and we learned
things like the united nations has
enacted more meta-human censures and
there's a reason why meta-humans are
censured which basically means their
their ability to act publicly or speak
or what have you is curtailed not
necessarily in the sense that anything's
actually being done right these are
toothless measures that are happening
but what norman tells us here is he says
that he and wesley dodds and and his
wife you know norman's wife that they
were all friends at one point and wesley
would come over and they would talk and
different things along those lines but
he says before the bitterness overcame
him wesley and i would walk right we
would pick our way through the city for
hours he'd bemoaned the passing of
things like olympic games and nobel
prizes sometimes he'd ambush complete
strangers and ask them how much they
missed of the concept of human
achievement and he says i don't know
what surprised me more the oddity of the
question or the growing number of people
who seemed to know what he was talking
about i tried to defuse him i would joke
that he was just some old guy unable to
appreciate this new generation but he
would never laugh that wesley insisted
that human initiative began to erode the
day people asked a new breed to face
their future for them essentially the
first time heroes began to crop up and
the first time humanity looked at heroes
to save them instead of humanity saving
themselves and he says he mocked their
worth these newcomers and spoke instead
of legends gone of costume champions who
had in his day inspired human
achievement not belittled it he swore
he'd never forget the world they came
from he wanted them to be remembered and
that's when you have norman mckay who
goes into planet krypton which is
obviously a play on planet hollywood and
when he's in there it's basically this
entire restaurant modeled after the
superheroes of yesteryear green lantern
wonder woman aquaman the flash these
different guys batman superman and so on
that the idea of superheroes has become
almost a kind of thing that's a joke but
it's almost a a kind of commercialized
concept that instead of wonder woman
standing for righteousness and paving
the way for women to progress instead of
superman representing everything
humanity can become instead of batman
representing what it means to be a dick
uh what you have is all these different
characters who basically represent
nonsense right they represent
commercialization and they represent the
loss of what it means for society in
terms of humans actually being something
that's worth the damn and so what
happens is he says the sandman had gone
to his grave without one grain of faith
in the future and the saddest part was
he was far from alone with each passing
day hope for tomorrow has become more
and more precious a commodity among
everyday folk still i tried to keep the
faith and hew to the scriptures
according to the word of god the meek
would someday inherit the earth but god
never accounted for the mighty now this
is where we get the reality of how
things had shifted now we'll find out
later on in terms of what had actually
taken place that it led to this shift
but what he says here is that the world
that wesley dodds had left behind was
not the world that he remembered you
know wesley dodds the sandman was from
the world of superman and wonder woman
and green lantern the flash these heroes
that represented everything humanity was
was striving to be that we as human
beings are fallible and and we usually
screw up more than we do things right
not because we're somehow incompetent or
inept we are in a lot of ways but only
because we as human beings don't learn
until we fail if we could somehow know
what the end result of our cons or of
our actions were going to be what those
consequences would be we would never
make mistakes but it's only by making
mistakes that we get better and we look
back on the consequences of those
choices that we truly begin to realize
what it is we lost or gained or anything
along those lines and then what had
happened here is somewhere along the
line the traditional superheroes of old
with dc comics superman flash and all
those guys they're out of the picture
and instead they're now replaced by all
these different heroes all these
different super powered beings that
exist out there but what norman says is
i tell myself that this too shall pass
that humans still have a chance to
reclaim a world rightfully theirs while
it still exists this is the face of
superhuman might and superhuman odds
time has not yet run out for humanity
and so the reality here is that when it
comes to all these superpower beings out
there where initially they seem to rise
up and replace these various superheroes
that we're the most familiar with which
of course again we'll get back to them
but one you know as these characters
rose up instead of them becoming a new
breed of superhero that could basically
help the world and make it a better
place that could somehow lead them into
a greener pasture instead of doing that
now these descendants of superman and
wonder woman and all these guys right
these next generation of superheroes
even if they're not the biological
children of of superman and all those
different guys that now they just fight
for the sake of fighting right they just
face off against each other for the sake
of facing off against each other there's
no wrong or reason here there's no
greater cause being served by all this
it's just people fighting for the sake
of fighting and there's a lot of
innocent people who get caught in the
collateral damage now one of the things
that we'll find over the course of
kingdom come is that humanity actually
brought it on itself that this whole
situation that you're seeing here is a
perfect example of be careful what you
ask for you just might get it because
humanity did this to itself and again
that's kind of the nature of what mark
wade says here is that we as people
don't learn our lessons until we screw
up but amidst all this fighting that's
taking place here suddenly in times
square there's a journalist that comes
on from the daily planet you may be
wondering why it's not lois lane you'll
find out
but basically she says like a
catastrophic event has happened in
kansas and so before we find out what
that is we actually end up following
norah mckay once he returns to his
church and the reality here is the role
he plays as as the head of the church
right with his congregation is to
instill hope in people whose hope is
barely hanging on by a threat right
wrong or otherwise regardless of how you
see religion in a lot of ways it really
is just a concept of hope that's really
all it is a construct for hope how much
faith people put in what they're hearing
and how much conviction they tie to what
they believe it really just shifts from
one person to the next but religion as a
whole is really nothing more than just a
hope construct that some people latch
onto for the idea of finding a better
tomorrow or making sense out of the
world in which they live but norman
mckay cannot provide this congregation
with the hope that they're looking for
all these individuals who have grown up
in a time before all these new
superheroes rose up and just started
going crazy they remember what the world
was like and they're looking to norman
mckay to help guide them back to
remembering what that world was and that
this won't all be this way but norman
mckay has a hard time being hopeful and
in fact he tells him i can't do this i'm
sorry i can't lie to you i can't fill
you with hope when i don't even have
hope myself and so his congregation of
course basically ends up leaving they
don't so much abandon him but they do
feel a bit of trepidation and
trepidation and shame as they look at
him and they see a man who has seemingly
lost the faith so how could a man with
no faith possibly lead people who are in
need of faith and that's when a
significantly important thing happens in
the life of norman mckay when he's
visited by the spectre now this is
probably the part that you're waiting
for for a lot of you guys out there who
had never read kingdom come yes the
beginning of the story seems to have
nothing to do with dc or any of the
heroes we know it takes a little bit to
kind of get to that point but it all
begins to make sense and so when the
spectre shows up here and basically
tells norman mckay i need your aid here
this vector basically ends up revealing
to norman mckay what his purpose is not
fully but basically giving him an idea
and simply saying i have been sent here
by a higher power in order to judge the
world now here's the thing about this
right that when it comes to the spectre
back when he initially came into
existence he operated independently one
of the things that dc did in order to
both make the spectre more grounded as
well as potentially give him a weakness
as well as have him essentially
have a greater involvement in the dc
landscape was basically bond him to
people and that by bonding the specter
to individuals it was a way to almost
turn the specter from this ethereal you
know godly imbued being to what was
basically a superhero it was kind of
like that in the beginning but the the
way the spectre initially appeared back
in the old school all american comics
basically began to move away and it
began to shift so by the time you got to
the events of crisis on infinite earth
he was just this wildly powerful
ethereal force that would just show up
every once in a while and while it was
kind of cool dc was wanting to bring him
back to the world of being a superhero
and so that's one of the ways in which
they did that plus it was cool to have a
person who was basically the embodiment
of god's wrath walking around the world
and so what ends up happening is the
spectre basically tells norman mckay you
have been imbued with a portion of the
power that wesley dods had but more so
than that you are going to be my eyes
and ears here on earth and where norman
mckay is just kind of like why in the
world like what what how could i
possibly be suited to fit this and even
himself doesn't fully seem to comprehend
everything that's going on one of the
things he says is explain this to me
right if you are truly a being of great
power how is it that you can find no way
to avert this catastrophe that you say
is coming this armageddon that you say
is going to take place and the response
of the specter is that is not my task
once earth boasted other saviors who
might have stemmed the tide of
destruction but as you will see they are
no longer the solution they are in many
ways the problem and so what the spectre
does is he brings norman mckay on a
journey to show him all these different
individuals who are the superheroes of
yesterday what happened to batman what
happened to superman what happened to
wonder woman green lantern the flash
those guys and so what we find out here
is he's taken to superman basically on a
farm and that as superman goes around
here of course wesley dodds whispers and
whatnot the response to the specter is
no no no you're good they yeah he can't
hear you right he can't see or hear you
i have shielded you from this uh i am
that powerful right that not even the
man of steel who can hear virtually
anything can hear you here superman is
effectively met by the arrival of wonder
woman and the cool thing is that wonder
woman the way she speaks here is she
simply says or at least uh you know
communicates that she's been coming here
relatively frequently now one of the
things that i do want to establish here
is that superman does not respond to the
name clark i mean he does but he
responds with disdain right that's not
my name so when wonder woman refers to
him as clark she corrects herself then
refers to him as cow and that's when he
starts talking to her right he was like
you know i haven't seen you in months
what brings you to the farm and this is
what's really interesting here is she
says the vain hope that you're still not
here and superman says these are my
roots right to which he responds you
can't live forever in solitude that what
superman has done here is basically cut
himself off from the rest of humanity
isolated himself in his entirety from
everybody else and what he says is
things can grow here right this place
that i'm in life can really grow and
flourish here and that's when wonder
woman responds but it's all a farce and
when she touches the wall and basically
reveals he's in the fortress of solitude
that he's not actually out there in the
world living it really is superman
living a lie right you know she's she
literally chimes in and she says listen
to me like you have to do something
right like i've come with news from the
outside and it's bad news that news has
that has an effect shaking the world
that he's out of control and that's when
superman says i tried to tell them that
10 years ago i tried to tell them they
backed the wrong horse that they should
not have gone along with that guy but
they did and of course as a result of
that by removing himself from humanity
what superman's doing is effectively
saying i could save you but i'm not
going to you chose this path now you
have to live with it and humanity's been
regretting it every single day and in
fact wonder woman picks up on that and
she says and they don't listen i know
stop punishing them and the response to
superman is i don't care right they
deserve whatever fate they got they
brought it on themselves i feel nothing
for them i have no desire to help them
at all and she says okay fine if that's
true right if if that's really the case
then come with me and let me show you
the world as it exists right now let me
show you the outside world because
you've been hiding from it you've been
ignoring it you've been pretending like
it doesn't exist you cut yourself off
from it just go and watch and see what's
become of the world but steal yourself
right be prepared for what it is that
happens and so he ultimately walks into
his area with the viewing screens and he
simply just says on and that's what we
end up finding out there's just a
colossal event that's taking place that
what had happened is the the villain
parasite had basically been chased down
by the by magog as well as his at least
what's referred to as the justice
battalion now magog of course was the
character that you saw in infinite
frontier and we'll talk more about him
as the story unfolds because he turns
out to be hugely important but it was a
massive fight between parasite and all
these different guys and parasite was
literally just trying to flee but it was
one of these things where he was begging
for his life he was begging for begging
to be saved he tried to surrender they
wouldn't let him surrender they quite
literally just wanted to kill him and so
in an act of desperation what parasite
had done is he had torn captain adam in
half or at least split him and when that
happened it basically set off a massive
explosion and what we're told is that
early reports indicate immediate
casualties numbering close to a million
as the dying atoms radioactive energy
swept hundreds of kilometers rendering
the entire state of kansas as well as
part of nebraska iowa and missouri in a
radiated wasteland though magog's
comrades have since prevented further
spread of the nuclear blight the total
loss of america's breadbasket this
sterilization of its agrarian culture
has thrown the world economy into near
collapse in the face of global famine
that's what we're looking at here quite
literally the entirety of the american
agricultural industry has just been
annihilated by the force of magog and
the recklessness that came with just
attacking the attacking parasite in that
way and so the response to superman even
after having seen all that is there's
nothing i can do from here go back to
your island diana you're safe there and
walks away right and literally just kind
of like that's it there's nothing i can
do and so you know in that instance the
response of wonder woman is we won't all
sit here and wait like we won't all deal
with this right we're not all going to
sit here and rest on our laurels and
that's when norman mckay asked the
spectre neither will the rest of us who
is she talking about and the spectre
takes him on a tour of a few others and
says that the the idea of superman
abandoning his role as a superhero had a
huge effect on the entire superhero
landscape that some some heroes out
there were so disheartened because they
took their lead from superman they were
so disheartened by seeing him so
demoralized that when he quit they quit
that there were others out there who
basically started functioning in a way
to where they keep their city safe but
nobody ever sees them a really good
example of this is the flash right the
flash just races around the entirety of
keystone city keeping it safe keeping it
protected but nobody ever sees it nobody
ever knows he's there that you have
hawkman who basically operates out in
the pacific northwest as kind of an
environmental protector that you have uh
the green lantern who quite literally
made an emerald citadel for himself that
orbits the earth he's the s the only
occupant there and he spends all of his
days watching for an extraterrestrial
threat that will seemingly never come
that all these different people out
there all these members of the superhero
community in their own ways effectively
did the exact same thing superman did to
a degree now of course you end up having
norma mckay who says but what happened
to batman what happened to gotham city
and what it looks like here is that in
the city of gotham one batman's got an
entirely automated system that runs and
two no crime is tolerated in any
capacity whatsoever none right batman
has actually become far more extreme
than he was when superman existed
because superman represented hope and
even if batman didn't necessarily put
that perception on it permeated him
right the hope he experienced with
superman was the hope that gotham city
could truly become a better place and
the only thing we get here is the
specter telling norman mckay batman has
a city under control and so what happens
is you have norman mckay who is taken to
a bridge and this is probably one of the
single greatest moments in the entirety
of kingdom come he asked them the
question like that's all that's what you
wanted to show me and the specter asks
does that disturb you and the response
of of norman is yes right you're an
angel that makes you a messenger of hope
a greater power sent you your very
existence is a testament to faith you
mean that all you have to tell me is
that those who could save us simply
won't and that's the thing that norma
mckay can't quite grasp his head around
is they could save us it's not like they
were killed they didn't die in action
they just won't they simply just won't
save us and i don't understand why why
are we as humanity simply not worth
saving and so that's when norman mckay
has to come to grips with the fact
humanity did it to itself and so in this
moment when you're on this bridge you
end up having all these these you know
heroes like a great big fight breaks out
here pandemonium starts reigning supreme
you got the heroes against villains if
you could call them that and as usual
people are caught in the crossfire it's
just absolute pandemonium and in fact
what has happened is that in the
aftermath of kansas that because of the
lengths that magog and his forces went
to in order to take out a parasite that
now it kind of feels like all bets are
off right that whenever it comes to this
bar of recklessness and lack of concern
for collateral damage every time he gets
raised by magog everybody else follows
suit so in a lot of ways he's kind of
the opposite of superman right his
antithesis and so it's really kind of
crazy how this how this goes on and so
what you end up getting is in the midst
of all this right you literally have
people who were stuck in a cable car
about to fall to their death right it's
virtually the end of these guys and you
have this thing where it's like can
anybody get out here right norah mckay
the whole time is like don't you
understand right talking to the specter
if any of us are to survive any of us
now more than ever we need hope and then
he says and suddenly there was a wind
right not a not really a wind a blur of
motion bending the steel of their
weapons and changing the very course of
the mighty river below he says even
before the bystanders freed themselves
from the cable car they knew we all did
we knew and we remembered and somebody
says look somebody else says up in the
sky and it's superman who's finally
returned with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this to an end let me know
what you guys think down in the comments
section if you guys want me to finish
this i feel like you guys are gonna be
like yes
[Laughter]
because kingdom come it's just one of
the absolute greatest stories ever in
the history of dc comics right it's so
cool because you get this little moment
here right this little this little kind
of uh kind of a small moment and when
when norah mckay basically says superman
had not turned his back on us right he
stands in the sky faith rewarded he has
returned and dear god the threat of
armageddon hasn't ended it's simply just
begun
all right what's going on guys this is
rob and we are back with kingdom come
part two yes we are part dos now here's
the thing superman and the justice
league as we know them have effectively
returned right superman wonder woman
hawkman all these different characters
they've all basically returned back to
the landscape so what we're looking at
now is a scenario where the superheroes
of old have returned to face the
superheroes of new now this is where
things get really really interesting
because on the surface we would look at
that and we would say okay so like the
day saved and everything's gonna be
sorted out we're pretty far from that
actually and things are gonna get a lot
worse before they get better so what
this does is it initially picks up at
the statue of liberty and you've
basically got this crazy guy right like
the american commando and his minutemen
is what he calls him now the thing about
this here is he just kind of goes on
this just ultra i wouldn't even call it
patriotic so much just ultra insane
ranch where he says like this is my
country right for years the america
mando and the minutemen have protected
the us from foreign threats only to have
overlooked the most insidious menace of
all the poor tired huddled masses
camping on our shores begging for
citizenship you immigrants dare expect
sanctuary america's not as big as it
used to be for god's sakes kansas is
gone we can't house you now we can't
even feed you now but still you force
yourselves on us well no more today the
america mando declares war on the
wretched refuse and at that point you
basically have all these guys who start
attacking these people who were looking
to make their way into the united states
now while all that goes on what you have
is another of these really just
anti-hero groups out there that just
attacked the amir commandos and again as
we talked about before what you have
here in this instance are basically
feral superheroes it's the best way to
look at it that traditionally in dc
comics the emergence of superman while
he didn't really present himself as the
de facto leader in the standard by which
all superheroes should follow it just
kind of ended up that way the superman's
morale was almost unquestionable and
incorruptible what you have here are
basically people with powers and no
leadership whatsoever right it's an
answer to the question what will people
do in a circumstance when there is no
one to lead them they'll do whatever it
is they want to do and the the rules or
any collateral damage won't really make
any difference it's a really really
interesting critique on people who are
like we should not have an ordered
government okay well if you look at the
nature of humanity what is the average
person without someone telling them what
to do or where to go they're people who
just do things arbitrarily and never
take into account the wants or desires
or the consequences of their actions on
other people it just becomes lawlessness
and it'll only lead to chaos and
destruction and so it's really really
interesting how this is critiqued how
that concept is looked at and put
through the lens of these superheroes
because what you get is in the middle of
all this you have the justice league
that arrives here now contrary to to
what you might think in the sense of
superman and then just show up and start
pummeling everybody while they do bring
an end to this fight what superman does
is he basically presents himself and the
justice league to these people and
basically gives them an option right you
can join us or you can be dealt with now
there is a way in which they're dealt
with and that way doesn't necessarily
come until well really towards you know
in this story but it's one of those
things where superman's hand is kind of
forced instead what he does is he kind
of repairs the statue of liberty as best
he can kind of presenting himself as a
beacon of hope and then in turn
basically uses the numbers of all these
vigilantes and brings them to his side
now that's an important distinction that
i want to make here when it comes to
these different heroes out here again
they're not really villains they're more
just feral like they've never really had
any direction they've never been taught
any better one of the things to know and
what's kind of interesting is this book
in a lot of ways throws into sharp
relief the idea of like social
constructs different things like that
like if you scale out right if you look
at like how people function on a
day-to-day life or look at your life and
then you scale out and look at it at a
macro scale we as human beings largely
just do things because that's just what
you're supposed to do we don't question
it we don't really ask why we just do it
because everybody else does that social
norms and social constructs are largely
just created in order to provide a sense
of comfort and that anybody who deviates
outside of these unspoken social norms
has to be quote unquote corrected and
brought back in again even if what we're
doing is entirely stupid and ridiculous
and doesn't really make any sense a
really good example of this is the mitch
hedberg joke right that like escalators
that are broken are basically just
stairs so why would you be an idiot and
take stairs instead of taking the
escalator right but we don't think about
that we're just like oh the escalator's
not working i'll take the stairs instead
even though that's basically stairs
and we all do that and so that's why
it's kind of interesting when somebody
just sort of looks up and says why am i
doing this right because the response of
everybody around them is shut up stop
asking questions get your head back down
and then they just continue on just like
they did before right so you know
violating social norms is kind of looked
down upon which really kind of makes you
beg the question who's the one that
really is screwed up here is it the one
who's asking the question why am i
following these social norms or is it
the one who's telling that person to
stop asking questions and to follow
those social norms but the thing about
this is that these heroes don't have a
leader there's no one out there for you
know to really tell them here is how
heroes are supposed to act they're feral
and so superman presenting himself in
this way is quite literally giving these
people the kind of you know person to
follow or the kind of ideology to a
degree now you're going to find over the
course of this that there is a lot of
hypocrisy that goes on there and a lot
of things that don't necessarily seem to
make sense but following all of that
superman and his guys you know the
justice league appear basically before
the united nations at a kind of press
conference and they say look like we've
been gone for a really long time right a
lot of you or at least some of you all
may remember who we are some of you may
not but the fact that we've been gone
that's our mistake and he says in our
absence a new breed of metahumans has
arisen a vast phalanx of self-styled
heroes unwilling to preserve life or
defend the defenseless a legion of
vigilantes who have perverted their
great powers who have forsworn the
responsibilities due to them we have
returned to teach them the meaning of
truth and justice together we will guide
this new breed with wisdom and if
necessary with force above all we will
restore order we will make things right
again now there is an attempt by various
members of the press to ask some
questions but for the most part they're
not necessarily answered there is a
point where superman is asked well what
if this leads to you having to face
magog to which superman just kind of
looks away and seems to avoid the
question and then basically just ends up
taking off now one of the things that we
are kind of given here and at least you
know we're given this kind of moment
where superman transitions to wayne
manor of course we knew it was only
going to be a matter of time before he
would confront bruce wayne and this
interaction between the two is really
really cool because when superman gets
there wayne manor is trashed i mean this
place is just torn up i mean obviously
it's just experienced some pretty rough
times and superman finds batman down in
the cave but one of the things to notice
here is that there is no happiness from
batman to see superman and in fact this
exchange is phenomenal because what you
have here is superman who says uh batman
i know you're here right like you cannot
hide from me and the response of batman
is i bow to your superior wisdom after
all you know all about hiding don't you
clark and it's one of those things where
batman holds a lot of animosity towards
superman now what's interesting here is
that the debate between the two is that
superman has always believed that
mankind should be led to a better future
right if the world becomes a better
place it's because superman and the
actions of the superheroes show humanity
that they can become better but you
could argue that's a very naive
perspective right that superman is john
tuturo from miller's crossing right when
you have gabriel byrne with a gun
pointed at his head and superman says
look into your heart right that's what
he is whereas batman is the realist
right batman looks at humanity and says
no if given the opportunity humanity
will just do crazy and violent things i
mean look at these vigilantes that exist
out there they're an answer to your
question superman what is humanity at
its core what will humanity become when
you take away consequences it's the
grocery carts litmus test those of you
guys who are unfamiliar with that the
grocery cart litmus test is this really
really fascinating ideology what it says
is that when you go to the grocery store
and you buy your groceries and you put
them in the cart and then you put them
in the car and so on and so forth and
then you're done the grocery cart is
sitting right there and that's when the
test comes into play right there's no
reward for putting the grocery cart back
inside the cart corral and that's what
it's called i don't know what it's
actually called but there's a there's no
reward for doing that but it is the
right thing to do however if you don't
do that and you just leave the grocery
cart out there in the middle of the
parking lot there's no punishment for
that so what will a person do when
there's no reward for doing the right
thing but no punishment for doing the
wrong thing what will they end up doing
here and the argument that batman's
making here albeit absent the grocery
cart litmus test although i would love
to have seen that in the comic
as he says the world in which you see
clark is the answer to that question the
world that you see out there that's what
it looks like when you have metahumans
where there's no consequences for doing
the wrong thing but no benefit for doing
the right thing outside of a you know
moral pat on the back they'll do
whatever they want to do and that right
and wrong won't matter anymore right and
wrong or completely and totally
irrelevant there's just simply what a
man can do and what a man can't do and
that's it those are the only rules that
apply here so you championing how great
humanity can become the evidence runs
contrary to everything that you believe
and that's why batman had basically
turned gotham city into what's
essentially a dictatorship where he
where he rules it with an iron fist now
there's a few different reasons why this
had happened the first one is because
once batman's identity became publicly
known bane and two-face showed up and
just wrecked wayne manor now of course
they weren't able to access the batcave
hence the reason why all this stuff is
still intact the other reason why is
because there came a point uh where
essentially arkham asylum was just
annihilated and basically all the
villains that were in it were basically
killed so there's very few of any of
batman's traditional villains left if
any at all instead now it's all just
sort of meta humans that are there the
meta humans those ones that just kind of
do whatever it is they want presumably
dealt with batman's villains but the
reality is that in the absence of all
that the gotham city in the eyes of
bruce wayne is a utopia there is no
crime none of that stuff now people
don't necessarily have the same free
will that they had before but as we've
seen so far with regards to all these
meta-humans what will people do with
complete and total freedom they'll go
crazy right they'll basically destroy
things that right and wrong simply won't
matter it's just it's a really really
interesting idea here and i love the way
this is put together and so that's where
you have just kind of a splitting of
ideologies here that at the end of the
day there is no real way to find any
measure of unification and in fact
batman even goes as far to tell superman
you are just as naive as you ever were
like you really believe that humanity's
this great thing but rest assured right
like there's myself and the people i
work with whose names you will never
know we see humanity for what it really
is and what you see here in gotham city
we will try to extend this to the rest
of the world because humanity by its
very nature needs to be controlled if
there's no one telling people where to
go or what to do then people will be
lost they'll be just chaotic and
nonsensical right they'll do things that
are quite literally worse for society
because whether or not something's
better for society won't matter to them
they'll operate on their own selfish
instincts the world has shown us that
humanity has shown us that so we have to
control them because they cannot control
themselves now initially superman ends
up leaving instead of just creating a
confrontation with batman he basically
walks away and you end up finding out
that the various people that bruce wayne
has on his side include people like ted
cord and dinah lance and oliver queen
that these are some pretty intelligent
and capable forces that are out there
more so than that what batman also says
is with the justice league returned and
the justice league reforming what
superman's going to do is all those
different meta humans out there who were
just rogue and doing their own thing
it's only going to be a matter of time
before they basically join his ranks
which means the the ranks of the justice
league are going to bolster which means
we have to find our own team we have to
build our own team up this includes
people like like black adam it includes
people like dr fate and so on and so
forth we've got to build our own team
and so what you end up getting is this
moment where as time goes on you have
superman who is meeting with different
groups out there right these these meta
humans and whatnot who are just
rampaging and causing all kinds of
problems and whatnot and basically
teaching them direction now not all of
them join the side of superman and we're
not really given an immediate answer as
to what it is that happens to them
instead for the most part the ones who
do agree with superman basically join
his side but what we end up doing is
transitioning to another group out there
which is basically called the mankind
liberation front and what this is is a
coming together of humans across the
world now one of the funny things here
is despite its name not all of them are
directly tied to humanity i mean they
are but they also kind of have they have
powers essentially so you could argue
meta humans and the reason why i say
this is because one of the first people
that we're met with is vandal savage now
depending on how you want to look at
dc's history you could take that
traditional history of vandal savage as
it exists regarding dionysium and the
substance he consumed that basically
made him immortal you can apply that to
kingdom come if you want to and say in
this alternate reality that's basically
how he came to be of course that whole
dionysium thing was established in the
new 52 batman run by scott snyder uh
vandal savage is not just a guy who's
going to live for like probably 85 to 90
years and then die of age he's immortal
but regardless this this mankind
liberation front is headed up by lex
luthor and you have a few different
people here one of whom is al zuffasch
who's basically the successor to rajal
ghul then you also have of course lord
naga you've got selena kyle you've got
the riddler edward nigma and the cool
thing is that what you find is that
behind the scenes with a lot of things
that's going on the mankind liberation
front is actually working to make life
more difficult for humanity and i know
it seems counter-intuitive that they're
doing things like impeding rescue
efforts right or they're getting the
getting in the way of uh food and
resources that are being brought to the
united states from different places and
so on and so when the question is being
asked how is any of this helping
humanity which is the charter under
which you operate the response of lex
luthor is simply no pain no gain he says
our objective is to heighten the tension
between humans and metahumans to bring
it to a head so that humans have no
choice but to reclaim the being of world
power regardless of the cost there will
be war bloodshed but in the end mankind
will once again rule the earth now the
reason why he says that of course
obviously he wants to be him and this
council that rules everything but the
reason why he makes this argument is
because for years what has happened is
humanity has handed the reigns over to
superheroes to keep them protected
that's the way it was when you initially
had the justice league it's the way it
was when the justice league disbanded
and we got this new generation of heroes
humanity ultimately bit off more than
they could chew they regretted the
decision they made but there was no one
willing to step up and save humanity
from itself now that the justice league
has returned humanity hasn't changed
it's not doing anything different than
it was before it's not like the
reformation of the of the justice league
led to humanity saying oh my god i see
the light we clearly made a mistake by
looking at superheroes and asking them
to save us no it was humanity looking at
the justice league and saying man the
world's such a terrible place save us
justice league show us a better way and
then when humanity made the decision
that it made which is what we'll talk
about later on in the story the justice
league disbanded and the anti-heroes
that rose up humanity was like yes
you're the ones we want and then when
the anti-heroes did exactly what they
would do which was showing really in a
lot of ways becoming a mirror for
humanity itself that humans were just
like no we don't want this this is not
what we wanted we want we want the
justice league back so the justice
league came back and they're like
justice league these meta humans are
going crazy you have to save us so it's
one of those things where humanity never
quite takes responsibility for itself it
never looks around at any point and says
maybe i'm the one responsible for all of
this instead it just blames everything
else on everybody else and so the idea
of the mankind liberation front is to
force the hand of humanity to make
things so dire that what the majority of
the human race does right what people in
general do is they look at meta humans
and say metahumans in their entirety are
the problem many humans are the reason
why all of this is the way it is we have
to get meta humans we have to get rid of
them completely and then once that's
done that will lead to humanity
re-inheriting the earth quote-unquote as
lex luthor puts it now the other part of
this is that lex does have an ace up his
sleeve it's one thing to interrupt trade
routes and to make resources more scarce
it's another to actually be able to
stand against superman and the justice
league what we end up finding out here
is the ace in the hole that lex luthor
has is actually shazam but before we
figure that out
before we find out about that what we
end up doing here is basically picking
up with a with a point where superman
and wonder woman go to visit aquaman now
initially they asked aquaman for aid but
the reality here is aquaman's like no
like i'm not i'm not helping you guys at
all one i never really wanted to be
aquaman i never wanted to be your
aquaman i was there more or less because
i wanted to ensure atlantis was
protected and because i didn't even
really initially know what you guys were
about right so in a lot of ways for
those of you guys coming from marvel it
was when black panther initially joined
the avengers he joined them to keep an
eye on not because he actually wanted to
be a part of the team and because he
believed in their cause as time went on
aquaman did to a degree but the reality
here is that when the time came when it
was obvious the justice league wasn't
going to reform superman was done he had
walked away and there would be no one
there to look out for atlantis that
aquaman's response was i'm gonna look
after my kingdom myself whatever happens
in the service world i don't care so
long as it doesn't impede here now this
is in reality and it's one of the things
that wonder woman points out it really
is aquaman sticking his head in the sand
and just waiting for the danger to pass
or hoping the danger passes the question
she has is how long do you think this
chaos on the surface will take before it
comes down here to the oceans and the
response of aquaman is well if that time
comes and i will deal with it then but
that's if that time comes at the moment
i don't really care it's not my concern
here and so it's a pretty significant
moment because one of the things that we
learn is that wonder woman had basically
been banished from themyscira she's not
allowed back anymore that she's lost her
title of princess that the reality here
is that with themaskira you know when
she had left that place and gone out
into the world she was supposed to be an
ambassador and she was supposed to make
the world a better place but she never
did she's not welcome back anymore and
so she has she's no longer the the
person that we knew but one of the other
things that goes on is you have this uh
this moment where superman actually
finally tracks down or really it's more
like speedy he finally tracks down uh
magog and then he actually travels to
meet him now in a lot of ways it's one
of these things that's fearful because
what this does is it tells us how things
got this bad why the justice league
disbanded why superman basically quit
the whole nine yards that what magog is
doing is he's actually out in kansas
seemingly trying to rebuild to a degree
and that's when superman asks like what
are you doing out here and you kind of
have this moment where magog basically
kind of pokes fun at him right just sort
of rustles his feathers a little bit
gives him a bit of a hard time
superman's not necessarily having it but
the mad dogs was like don't you remember
like you're the one who caused all this
right like you're the reason why things
are the way they are and that's when we
end up getting this bit of a flashback
and what we find out is that at some
previous point in time the joker had
shown up to the daily planet in
metropolis and massacred everybody 92
men and lois lane one woman and the
results of that is that with her being
killed along with jimmy olsen and
everybody else that the joker was
captured and the joker was put on trial
but before the trial could could
actually take place maggod showed up and
killed the joker and instead of humanity
condemning this action and saying that's
a problem humanity cheered the action on
they were like yes the joker had to go
the joker had to die and what this did
is it led to superman becoming
disheartened by the fact that everybody
was okay with it the magog was
eventually arrested and then when he was
put on trial he was acquitted and so it
was essentially humanity saying we're
okay with the fact that a meta human
took the law into their own hands and
killed a villain we don't really believe
in truth and justice anymore we believe
in doing whatever it takes to win now
the reality is that really is what it
takes that really is the case there are
some people out there that just have to
die the result of this is what you had
really the bigger issue that you had
here is that the magog wasn't really any
measure of a leader himself he was just
a guy out there with power and so when
he killed the joker and became the kind
of face of this new generation of
superheroes and superman abandoned his
role and the justice league disbanded as
well it left the stage open for all
these meta humans to rise now that's the
big difference there i do champion the
idea that there are some people out
there where the world would just be
better off without them that as a
society you have to create a kind of
structure right you can't have this kind
of open-ended idea where it's like
everybody can do whatever they want to
that makes them happy you know like you
do have to have a rigid and firm
structure on how society functions
otherwise you start running into all
kinds of problems and yes like maggot
killing the joker isn't him crossing a
line sure but if this was like superman
who had done it or something like that
things could potentially turn out
different now i know a lot of people are
gonna say like but rob in justice so on
and so forth superman was right in
injustice he was 100 right humanity
couldn't be trusted to make the world a
better place so superman had to do it
for them that if superman didn't step in
and do that humanity would have
eventually wiped out the whole world and
is one of what use is freedom to a
society that will use that freedom to
destroy itself i would say freedom is
useless at that point and so the the
thing about this is that you have this
kind of situation where ultimately the
magog comes clean i don't know why i
keep saying the mag but the uh but mega
i think it's because i'm used to saying
the man gog from uh from the thor comics
at marvel
[Laughter]
but magog comes clean and what's been
happening is he has this enormous weight
that he carries around because he never
wanted this he never wanted to be the
face of some new generation of vigilante
that showed up and turned the world into
a hellhole he never wanted to be that he
never wanted the entirety to the entire
destruction of kansas that's never what
he wanted here and so what he's what he
tells superman is i'm sorry right like
this is all your fault you were supposed
to be better than us you were supposed
to be great you were supposed to be the
one that showed us a better way you
weren't supposed to quit you were
supposed to show me what i was doing
wrong you were supposed to guide us at a
time when the world really actually
needed you you quit you gave up and so
he says like i'm tired of dealing with
all these ghosts that haunt me all these
like a million ghosts all these people
in kansas that haunt me punish me lock
me away kill me just make the ghost go
away right make my guilty conscience
disappear and that's when superman tells
wonder woman we are at war and the
reason why this matters is because
wonder woman having been a warrior and
so on and so forth the big concern of
the spectre and norman mckay is that if
anybody was going to push superman over
that edge and send him into a place
where he would potentially become a
dictator it would be wonder woman
because when you're a hammer everything
is a nail and so when you're wonder
woman and all you live to do is fight
and like defeat the enemy the idea of
things like nuance right the idea of not
everybody is an inherent bad guy and not
everybody needs to be treated the same
way that kind of thing goes away now to
a degree that's true treating people
decently does not mean treating people
equitably that if you are a person who
has known nothing but war in conflict if
someone showed up to you with a kind and
caring and gentle hand you would likely
see them as being weak because the
defining attribute of what makes a
person strong is whether they can
withstand and cope with that war type
environment right physical and emotional
and mental strength that's what defines
a valuable person you would see that
kind person as being weak whereas if you
are someone who comes from a kind and
gentle place you would look at somebody
who uses overbearing force to get their
point across as somebody who's
inherently weak because you value
strength through kindness and compassion
so again one of the things that wonder
woman doesn't really seem to have a good
grasp of is the nuance of that
everything can be treated the same way
so that's gonna be an element that's
actually gonna be very very important as
all of this goes on but one of the
things that superman does here is he
actually travels to apocalypse which is
the realm of dark side to visit with
orion now this is kind of a small little
deviation here like kind of a small
little thing it's not a great big huge
moment and in fact word had reached the
ears of superman that basically darkseid
had been overthrown by his son orion and
that when that had happened orion had
seized control of apocalypse but when
superman came here asking how can i as a
person right this this individual who's
supposed to somehow show these meta
humans a better way what do i do about
the ones who don't want a better way and
the responsible ryan is that's the issue
that i ran into when i took over
apocalypse and i replaced darkseid my
thought was that all these people who
live on apocalypse would love the idea
of freedom they would love the idea of
being able to live their lives as they
see they saw fit but what i found is
that because that's the the only life
they ever knew they don't want a
different life than that because it's
scary it's fearful the idea of change
giving them freedom is something they've
never known before comfort comes in
being a prisoner right and so because of
that when i gave them that freedom they
rejected it they rebuked it they didn't
want to have any of that right by just
literally getting rid of dark side and
no leader operating here they put me in
his place because they wanted someone to
rule them they wanted someone to conquer
them right to control them to tell them
where to go and what to do because for
us as people and you could kind of argue
by extension the people on apocalypse we
want to be controlled why we want
direction we want to be told where do
you go what do you know where to go what
to do how to act we want to say we don't
we like to say no i don't want that i
want to have a life where i can make my
own choices and do my own thing and live
my life as i see fit but when push comes
to shove and it really comes down to it
a lot of people out there who have the
opportunity to forge their own path
choose not to because it's scary it's
outside of what they're used to and if
being being given the choice between
stepping into that box or staying in the
box they're in they'll choose the box
they're in and that's that's the the
wisdom that orion offers here if what
they understand is being conquered if
what humanity and these people
understand is being made to do things by
force if what they understand is
imprisonment and pain then give them
that give them what it is that makes
them comfortable and so while it's not
necessarily superman approaching this
from the perspective of we're going to
make people suffer what he does is out
there in kansas this irradiated
wasteland he starts building a prison he
literally starts building together this
giant prison system where all those
individuals who stand against him will
be housed and so as the final little bit
of this video what we end up doing is
switching over to the mankind liberation
front where you have lex luthor
effectively telling everybody they've
brought someone on board that will
essentially help them to change the tide
to achieve their goal and effectively
eliminate the entire meta-human issue
once and for all allowing humanity to
effectively step into the role of being
the sole inheritors of the world and
this person is revealed to be batman
accompanied by ted cord and dinah lance
and oliver queen
what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back with kingdom come part three
yes enter shazam so i know this is
probably the one that a lot of you guys
have been waiting for um who were aware
of what we did you know in the last
video where we talked about how shazam
was a part of it it was pretty obvious
it's it's really really awesome right
let's check this out what we end up
getting here and one of the things to
keep in mind is that it's not
necessarily the specter and this is
something that i that i saw in the
comments it's not necessarily the
specter that's taking norman mckay on
all these journeys if anything it's the
visions of norman mckay that's leading
the spectre on all of this because
remember the spectre is there to judge
some future evil and he's very cloak and
dagger whenever he talks to norman mckay
about exactly what he's there for or
what his purpose is we as the audience
are well aware of the spectre we're well
aware of how dark and twisted he can be
but also how good he can be just
depending on who he's bonded to at that
particular point in time or whether his
spirit's gone insane but that's
something that we'll actually talk about
here in a little while but at the moment
switching back to earth what you get is
the completion of this prison that has
basically been built by superman oddly
enough it looks like that old legion of
doom headquarters from the uh what is it
the super friends where aquaman rode
around on a seahorse
and talked to fish that show did more
damage to aquaman as a character than
any meme that's ever been created by
humanity
because of that show everybody's like
aquaman rides seahorses and talks to
fish and no one could take him seriously
anymore but the thing about this is that
this prison that's being built here is a
really cool discussion because what the
specter says is that once the kansas
wastelands were stripped of radiation
superman's penitentiary was fast
completed the gulag was built to
imprison the deadliest and most
uncontrollable of the superhumans thanks
to its vast size it was intended to
house prisoners for months to come
within two weeks of its construction it
was filled beyond capacity and what this
illustrates here and it's one of the
most important things what this
illustrates here is to a degree how
quickly superman is falling now a lot of
this is coming off the heels of wonder
woman that's one of the things to keep
in mind that while she's not a true
villain in this story the position of
wonder woman is more of as we said in
the last video when you're a hammer
everything is a nail and so she doesn't
really understand the nature of
diplomacy she does to a degree insofar
as an ambassador from themyscira to
humanity can understand diplomacy but
there's a lot more to it there's nuance
there's a much bigger scene going on
here with regards to all these
meta-humans which is like we mentioned
before they have no real leader there's
no quote-unquote parent teaching them
how to function in this world without
superman this is what the world looks
like when you have meta humans and no
one likes superman to inspire guide or
lead them now the other part of this is
that in order for the prison to function
effectively and actually house these
people the justice league needed someone
who was capable of building a prison
that no one could escape from and can
only do that by being someone that could
escape from any prison they basically
enlisted scot-free mr miracle now we're
not given a whole lot about him for all
you super hardcore mr miracle fans i'm
sorry to say
we don't get a whole lot about this guy
all we're really told is that he was the
one that was instrumental in building
the prison building a place that no one
could escape from because he's a master
escape artist who can escape from
anywhere so if if he can build a place
no one can get out of that means no one
can get out of it but the bigger issue
that you have to contend with is that
what superman was trying to do was
balance the humanity of meta humans with
a prison system and so what he ended up
creating was this situation where you
had all these people who were there but
they all kind of had free reign they
could sort of move around and they could
do their thing he didn't want them to
feel like they were in some kind of like
a concentration camp or something that
starts to present a lot of issues
because what he does is he presents
himself to these people as someone that
can lead them into a better future but
the reality is the life they know is the
only life they've known they haven't
known a life where there's been some
greater force out there that can show
them the way all they've known is this
vigilantism so to them that's the
definitive life right it's one of those
things those guys who are familiar with
uh the allegory of plato's cave that's
what this is those you guys who don't
know what that is the allegory of
plato's cave is this idea that if you
had like three people who had basically
spent their entire life in a cave and
all they ever saw of the real world were
shadows projected on the cave wall to
them that is the real world right for us
we know that it's not real but it is
real to them and so if you were to take
them out of that cave and you were to
show them the world as it really exists
they would reject it as incomprehensible
because it just defies everything they
know and as we know as people in times
of desperation people will believe what
they want to believe logic and reason
and emotion have no bearing on that it's
just whatever makes them feel the most
comfortable and what makes these people
feel comfortable is the life that
they've been living suddenly this guy
just comes out of nowhere quite
literally strips them of this life they
had throws them into what is in effect a
prison system and then says i'm here to
improve you from their perspective it's
but there's nothing wrong with me
because they don't believe there's
anything wrong with him that's why he's
met with so much hostility and so what
you have is this kind of fight that
begins to break out to a degree but it
all is quelled pretty quickly but it
really is one of these things where
superman is in over his head he's
putting too much faith in those who
cannot who just cannot be trusted in
that way right he's putting trust in
people who have no reason to be trusted
he's trying to fix the broken who are
beyond repair and so that's what's kind
of crazy is because while all this goes
on you have of course the uh the mankind
liberation front that's watching all of
this unfold and coming to this
realization that nothing that superman
is trying to achieve is actually going
to work he is fighting a fool's errand
beyond that what you also have is the
quintessence now the quintessence are
basically a coming together of cosmic
forces if you want to call them that so
think of the quintessence as dc's
equivalent to the the sky fathers but on
seemingly a higher level of power
honestly there's no direct translation
between the quintessence and the sky
fathers but the sky fathers that marvel
has is about the closest you get to this
but within the dc landscape these are
some heavy hitters the spectre the
phantom stranger uh the wizard shazam
you have ganthet of the uh of the green
lantern or the guardians of the of the
universe you have some heavy hitters
here they're kind of an inner council
that basically monitors and watches
things to see how the universe unfolds
now the funny situation about this is
that as the spectre is watching all this
unfold that you have the quintessence
that's just like whatever happens on
earth that's their problem right earth
is a single world right it's just a just
tiny little ball of mud in an infinitely
expanding universe there's much bigger
things and more important things that we
need to worry about and the spectre asks
the question is that so and when the
answer or the response of the of the
quintessence is yes and he says then why
do you all spend so much time dealing
with humanity why are you observing this
for such a lengthy period of time if
humanity matters so little you would
give them no more of a thought than you
would some comet streaming across the
cosmos but you're facing like you're
literally focusing on humanity you're
focusing on this whole thing so on some
base level it's entirely possible that
you congregate in order to prevent each
other from interfering that each one of
you wants to be involved in your own way
you gant that want to gather the green
lantern court and send the green lantern
corps in to quell this entire thing you
phantom stranger want to do something
else or you the wizard shazam want to
step in in some capacity but each of you
have agreed to remain hands off you care
more than you're willing to admit now a
really important moment in the story
comes when norman mckay watching all
this unfold really just can't understand
can't hear anything they're saying
because i guess the conversation is not
meant for him that's really what he
speculates he's met by the arrival of
boston brand now boston brand being dead
man this is when we're starting to get
into this idea of the the religious and
mythological side of dc comics right for
those of you guys who are new to dc dc
has two sides you've got the
front-facing superhero side that's the
face they present to the general public
anybody who wants to start getting into
comics that's your superman batman
wonder woman justice league comics then
you have the other side you've got like
the vertical side the the idea of
mysticism religion god lucifer all that
kind of stuff boston brand and
everything the specter that's the other
part that's the mystical side the
religious side boston brand whenever you
see him usually in a story like this he
possesses somebody not always but the
idea of boston brand is that he's well
aware of the spectre and the phantom
stranger and this whole side of things
norman mckay is not and so where norman
mckay is basically a pastor who's
devoted his life to the belief in god
basically the presence that kind of a
thing showing up here and encountering
all this it is to a degree questioning
his faith and not to really be a
terrible person about it but boston
brand kind of pushes him over a little
bit further because what he basically
tells him is that you have no idea
what's really going on here in the
greater world do you like you read your
bible to your congregation you take the
words that you see in the book with an
absolute faith that up to this moment
can never truly be shaken you believed
that it was true but you never actually
had the facts you never really knew what
was going on now norman mckay can't
really be faulted for that because no
one had taken him on a journey like this
before nothing had ever happened in his
life that led him to believe that while
the book he was reading wasn't
necessarily false there was just more to
the to the equation than he was seeing
but what boston brand says is one you're
being taken on this ride by the spectre
and it is important that you undergo
this but one thing to know the spectre
just because he's some being out there
of divine nature does not mean he's
inherently good it does not mean that
that's the case he's like one of the
things you need to understand is that
when it comes to the notion of good and
evil that sure you've got things like
the presents you've got lucifer and all
the stuff contained within your book but
the reality here is the the situation as
it exists the real world as it you know
as if you could call it that right what
passes for you know a lack of a better
word here it's anything but that it's
just varying shades of grey good and
evil do not really exist out there it's
just whatever a person can do and can't
do so do not take everything the specter
tells you as an absolute truth he was
bonded to jim corgan he was a cop at one
point in time when he was just the
spirit of vengeance he went crazy
basically lost his mind became what you
would call evil for a while the guy is
not some genuine altruistic force out
there designed to just punish the wicked
on behalf of god it's not that that
black and white it's not that binary and
so he says take what he tells you right
listen to what he tells you and keep it
in the back of your head just don't take
it as an absolute truth and then he
basically walks away now this particular
moment with boston brand will become
incredibly important once we get to the
end of the story because it'll totally
change the way that norman mckay handles
things but on the other side of the
equation regarding the whole idea of the
mankind liberation front one of the
questions that i imagine a lot of you
all have is why is billy batson working
with lex luthor so the way this works is
we're not really given a definitive
answer here we'll actually get that here
in a little bit it'll really be on
behalf of batman that explains it the
thing behind this though is that billy
batson here as an adult is constantly
showed footage of superheroes just being
violent how superheroes are quote
unquote inherently bad now it's not
really lex luthor cooking the books here
he's showing uh shazam actual footage
he's showing him these actual things
that go on the difference is that much
like most things that exist here in the
world on the media side news and so on
and so forth he's only ever been given
one half of the story to serve a
particular purpose the other part of
this and what like lex luthor's doing is
he's channeling the knowledge of dr
savannah right mr mind now one of the
things to keep in mind is that kingdom
come is post crisis on infinite earth
but before the new 52 so the new 52
origin of mr mind and dr savannah don't
really apply here instead going by the
power of shazam way back in the 1990s
and 1996 that the way this played out is
that mr mine had basically taken over
savannah and then planned like an
invasion of earth right that kind of
thing what we're not told here but what
seems to be the case is that with mr
mind being a sentient being that could
operate by his own whim his own will and
desire and so on and so forth that maybe
something happens somehow dr savannah
managed to overpower mr mind or whatever
it is but the idea of a telepathic worm
was basically used here we're not really
given the details about how all this
unfolded all we know is using a worm to
mentally control other individuals
around him is how lex luthor's been
controlling shazam so there's a lot of
ambiguity there but one of the things
that does go on here is you do end up
having batman who's actually watching
all this unfold using a secret spy
device now of course what's also taking
place here is working with the the
mankind liberation front they're
basically weaponizing and creating a
whole bunch of these mech bats right
these these bat robots that can be used
to kind of operate in lieu of metahumans
in order to keep society in check now
one of the things that batman wanted to
establish with lex luthor is that what
they're looking for is to basically move
the world in a better direction right to
create world order not world domination
they're not looking to subjugate
humanity they're looking to lead
humanity in a better to a better future
and believe they can only do that
because they themselves are humans that
many humans just can't relate to
humanity in that way right because they
simply have a level of power that
humanity doesn't possess right that at
the end of the day if mankind were to
follow the will of god it would be due
more to fear than an actual love or
belief in the power that person
possesses and so what you have here for
the most part when it comes to billy
batson walking around is he basically
seems very inhuman in terms of his
appearance he smiles all the time and
never really shows any emotion or
anything like that and so it really it
really freaks people out it creeps them
out in a lot of ways like why is this
guy always smiling and looking like that
he looks like a robot like it's just
kind of strange and so what you also
have going on here and this is one of
the more important things that we don't
get a lot of a lot of exposition on is
martian manhunter because that's
probably a question that a lot of people
had where's martian man hunter and all
of us now what we end up finding out is
that martian manhunter basically keeps
himself under the guise as a regular guy
that you that at least attempting to use
the telepathy of martian manhunter is
very very limited here in order to keep
anybody from knowing what he actually is
and the reason why is because this guy's
mind is walking a nice edge then
following superman basically walking
away martian manhunter in
what was probably the most terrible
decision he could make had actually
telepathically reached out to the whole
of humanity and experiencing all of the
nature of humanity at one point in time
basically broke him but humanity like
the very core of human beings broke
martian manhunter he never truly
understood what humanity was about until
he touched all their minds at the same
time and so because of that where
there's an attempt by batman to utilize
the powers of martian manhunter to
effectively read the minds of the people
in the room to find out what their
actual goals and motivations are in the
end it simply just proves to be too much
and so martian manhunter just kind of
goes about his business and that's
seemingly the last we see of him for a
while but the thing about this is you do
have this kind of moment in the the
watchtower or really the i guess the
citadel of the green lantern where the
justice league watches everything and
for the most part they've quelled most
all of these meta-human threats that
exist around the world just by arbitrary
fighting and whatnot things have calmed
down like germany's clear all these
different locations but the funny thing
about this is that the flash picks up on
the presence of norman mckay and as a
result of that actually yanks norman
mckay out of this kind of invisible
barrier so to speak because the reality
is that with the spectre they had him
slightly out of phase with the universe
itself but as the flash he can phase
through dimensions so it was only a
matter of time before he saw something
that indicated norman mckay was there as
soon as he picked up on it norma mckay's
yanked out he subdued my power woman and
then questioned by superman and when he
when superman asked the question like
who are you and why are you here the
reality is that witnessing this guy's
presence firsthand actually meeting him
firsthand overwhelms norman mckay he
doesn't quite know how to respond he
ends up turning into what's basically a
babbling fool all the way to the point
that he starts basically running off
biblical scripture by just saying like
well the end times are coming and that
kind of stuff he sounds like a religious
kook babbling about how the the how
armageddon is coming the end of days is
here some crazy person that you would
just walk by on the side of the road and
pay no attention to and that's kind of
what superman does they basically
dismiss him because the well while this
is going on you have dick grayson as
robin who chimes in and says like
there's a riot in the gulag right like
we have to get to the gulag we have to
respawn and of course wonder woman steps
in and basically tells everybody what
they need to do and sends them out there
and then a great big huge debate takes
place between wonder woman and superman
when he asks the question why did you
override my authority why did you
undermine me and the the response of her
is why did i do that i saw a crisis i
reacted in a confident and unequaled
manner the others need to see that sort
of authority from someone pull yourself
together we're overdue for a meeting
with the united nations they can't help
but know about the gulag by now and the
response to superman is that i guarantee
they're wondering when we started making
up our own laws let's go and in meeting
with the united nations basically the
overall gist of this conversation is
humanity is losing faith in the meta
humans they're losing faith in
superman's ability to keep this entire
threat under control because where
superman responded by saying i can
corral them in i can get this whole
thing sorted out the reality here is
he's losing control that the gulag was
created as a prison he did what was
probably the worst possible thing which
is take all these people with all this
power and put them into one single
location it's a melting pot of just
anger and rage and madness that's
literally what it is tempers running
high the whole nine yards you've got
villains who are now being housed with
heroes because that's kind of how they
see themselves to a degree they all they
do all they know how to do is just fight
and so because that's all they know how
to do when it comes to solving their
problems any disagreement that that
arises between these different meta
humans is met with conflict they don't
understand the idea of diplomacy or
talking things down or having a
conversation or any of that stuff they
don't know there's a better way while
that whole thing goes down with regards
to this crisis in the gulag you do have
the the mankind liberation front that
finally decides it's the time to make
their move it's their time to decide
what it is that they're going to do
right how they're going to act here now
you do have lex luthor who effectively
grabs shazam and says now's the chance
right now's your time to deal with this
and when that happens batman
incapacitates lex luthor and that's what
we end up finding out that's why batman
was here in the first place that he
never really joined the the mankind
liberation front never really even
believed in their movement in the first
place what he wanted to know is what
happened with billy batson what's going
on with shazam because the reality here
is that shazam is probably the only guy
out there that can go toe-to-toe with
superman and in fact that's going to be
a major component of this story when we
get to part four superman versus shazam
but it's a really cool thing because
what we end up getting is this
explanation where batman had figured it
out and he says i'd suspected for a
while and jon jones telepathic probe
confirmed it it seems marvel's dual
identities are in quite a bit of mental
conflict all these years as batson grew
to manhood luther kept him in check by
turning him into a stew of schizophrenic
psychosis and he says my only goal in
outlying with you was to learn your
connection to captain marvel and the
entire global conflict he was the wild
card and i hate wild cards and so that's
the crazy thing here is because now we
know that when billy batson was a little
kid and superman had basically walked
away that that essentially lex luthor
took billy batson under his wing and
then using basically telepathic worms
the knowledge of mr mind or of dr
savannah had been keeping billy batson
under his thrall under his control the
problem here is you have batman who
tells his guys take out the mankind
liberation front right deal with those
guys and at the same time you also have
billy batson who basically races off
under the orders of lex luthor to find
superman and to deal with him but again
billy batson is still under the control
of lex luthor but that's the concern
that you have when it comes to batman is
because when he confronts uh shazam when
he finally you know encounters him and
you've got all these tubes that are
filled with all these worms that lex
luthor's been using on shazam and they
all start to kind of infiltrate billy
batson he finally shouts the word shazam
and becomes a superhero self and then
takes off at the direction of lex luthor
to find superman so that's the big issue
is what happens when these two meet how
is it all going to go down and so when
you have wonder woman and you have
superman who arrived back at the uh at
the the watchtower i guess we can just
start calling it that right like the
emerald citadel the justice league
watchtower is effectively what it is a
great big huge argument breaks out
between the two because what you have
here is this this point where superman
says yet another side of you that i'm
not comfortable with right this part of
you that's willing to do whatever it
takes to win and the response of her is
get used to this one a soldier
unprepared has no business calling
herself a soldier and the response of
superman is you know quote unquote more
amazonian wisdom right isn't it possible
that we've already won the big fight
once the rioters are calmed we can
instill some measure of peace and the
response of wonder woman is you always
were a bit vulnerable to magic because
superman cut himself on her sword be
careful the sword was a gift from
hephaestus it can carve the electrons
off an atom and and the question of
superman is did you expect to use that
on me and she says i expected to be a
soldier right so what this indicates is
that if it came down to it wonder woman
was willing to kill superman she was
willing to take him out that the sword
was effectively a backup plan and he
says i will not sanction lethal force
against me or any of the rioters i'm
uneasy with that blade because that's
the other part of the equation sure it
can be used on superman if it needs to
be but she's willing to kill those meta
humans superman is not and that's the
discussion that we had in the previous
video in any particular conflict wartime
video games sports whatever it is right
they're all forms of conflict there's
only ever two people involved or two
types of people involved at any
particular point in time the ones who
would like to win and the ones who want
to win who need to win and the ones who
would like to win are not usually the
ones who win because the ones who feel
like they need to win or have to win
they'll do whatever it takes the only
thing that matters is that they come out
on top superman is by all standards of
measurement what you would call a high
road defeatist he's a person that takes
the stance of saying i would rather die
and keep my morals intact right i would
rather lose and keep my morals then win
by betraying them but the reality here
is of what use would that do to anybody
right if the one who loses and keeps
their morals intact if they die if
they're out of the picture now all
that's left is the one who wins and
whatever it is that they want to do
there's no one there to stand in the way
so in effect they've quit they're a
defeatist they gave up right literally
maintaining their moral code is what
caused them to lose in the first place
and that's the real position here wonder
woman is the one that has to win that
needs to win she's the one that's
willing to beg borrow steal and kill for
superman it's a war of convenience and
that's why you see this conflict
unfolding the way that it is because he
says there are lines that we do not
cross we have rules and her stance is
and the prisoners don't that's why
they're prisoners and if they don't
remain prisoners your big blue marble
teeters on the brink you made the
decision to incarcerate them for the
good of mankind remember and he says and
maybe that was my mistake maybe i should
have let the humans decide how to deal
with this but at the end of the day it
was superman's screw-up that what he
failed to realize is that he's basically
fighting a war against people who don't
follow the rules while following the
rules himself and that desire to follow
the rules is how you lose that's his
weakness and so as this whole thing on
the whole thing unfolds you end up
having this communication that comes
from the green lantern who's like we
can't hold this right these guys are
just way too powerful for us there's too
many of them they're overpowering us
they're reaching the walls we cannot
keep this thing contained somebody has
to do something and we end up finding
out that one of the people that one of
the superheroes had been killed captain
comet had died so now members of the
justice league are dying because of
superman's high road defeatist attitude
and so what this does is it leads to
wonder woman stepping in and saying then
we're gonna go there and we're gonna do
whatever we have to do if that means we
have to kill every single meta human
that's housed in the gulag we'll kill
every single one either you can stay
back here and you can hope that things
work out or you can join us in this
conflict you can grow some balls and you
can make the decisions that need to be
made because this is a time of war are
you a winner or are you a loser choose
one and ultimately superman stays behind
and so that's one of the crazy things is
because in this moment he races off
actually where wonder woman takes off to
the gulag he races off to batman and
confronts him and says i need your help
and where batman's like no we've been
through that already superman fed up is
like i've had enough of this right this
is not the time for you to take some
kind of high road or be a dick or
anything like that right this there are
huge stakes here we literally have many
humans breaking out of this the united
nations is waiting on pins and needles
to decide what it is they're going to do
and if it comes down to it they're going
to go to the nuclear option so they
could very well just wipe us all out as
meta humans the entirety of our future
hinges on this it hinges on this whole
thing and the response of batman is what
did you think was going to happen you
took every single metahuman that you
deemed to be a bad guy and put them in
one place you took a huge group of
people tons of people who don't know how
to solve any problem other than fighting
over it and you put them in one place
and gave them free reign you created
this circumstance you set this whole
thing up you're the reason why this is
happening in the first place it even
says like do you mean to tell me
superman that you you you mean to tell
me you never imagined that it might come
to this did you ever consider that war
might actually be for the best that
perhaps humanity's only chance is for
the superhumans to swallow each other
right to basically annihilate each other
it's the best chance humanity has of any
of having any kind of meaningful future
and this debate back and forth rages in
such a way to where it's like either you
can do something or a batman or you can
do nothing because lest we forget you're
a member of the justice league and so
before you take this high stance of it
is humanity's chance right it's time for
superhumans to go you were along with us
you're the smartest man in the world
maybe depending on lex luthor do you
really think they're not gonna come
after you do you really think they're
gonna say well all the metahumans have
to go and by metahumans we mean anybody
who has powers batman's cool do you
really think that's what they're gonna
say no they're gonna come after you
because you have the ability to affect
the world on a global scale maybe not
with powers but certainly with your
intelligence you represent a clear and
present danger and then the response of
batman here is like okay fine and he
says i will tell you this one thing i'm
not going to help you on all this but i
will tell you this one thing there's a
player that you have not counted on and
that's marvel that's literally captain
marvel billy batson and superman's taken
aback and he says he's been brainwashed
severely once there was a good kid
inside him but he's basically been
driven out and i don't know how you'd
ever find him again he's lost right
billy batson is headed to the gulag he's
gonna break it wide open onto the
justice league he's literally gonna
unleash all the superheroes out there
and he's going to initiate a
circumstance where humanity is going to
respond with nuclear arms and when that
happens it's game over right like it's
that's it there's no coming back you all
get nuked maybe some of you survive but
ultimately the entirety of the human
race will see you as the reason why it
happened and so ultimately you end up
having shazam who arrives on the scene
superman gets there just in time right
tries to get there just just before it
happens but he's too late shazam smashes
the place open right as superman gets
there and then before he can do anything
shazam stops him dead in his tracks
all right what's going on guys this is
rob and after four days we are here yes
we are here at the conclusion of kingdom
come yes i'm gonna be on a cruise by the
time this video comes out so uh i'll see
y'all in like a week
i'm gonna be getting tanned i'm gonna be
getting drunk i'm gonna be having a
great time hanging out with my sister
right she and i we love taking trips
together so here's what we're gonna do
right here's here's how this whole thing
works this video is basically the end of
it all right the battle the huge
conflict that happens now this is
literally everybody against everybody to
some degree the reality here is that
much like the various vigilantes that
they fought to overcome superman shazam
batman wonder woman all of them there
really aren't any good guys or bad guys
anymore it's really just descended into
superheroes fighting superheroes that's
really all it is because a lot of old
wounds are coming back out now right a
lot of injuries are coming back out a
lot of anger a lot of disdain a lot of
hurt is coming back to the surface and
that's what's happening here we get this
really really cool statement that's
offered where it said is that the only
reason i'm here of course norman mckay
talking to the specter and he says to
watch some hideous judgment superman and
i share the same terror his face is a
mask of confusion he cannot comprehend
how things came to this once upon a time
captain marvel was one of his mightiest
allies now whichever wisdom he once
possessed has been dulled by luther's
brainwashing making the captain a
soldier of chaos the one warrior who can
counter superman's every move and
prevent him from containing this battle
superman believes himself to be the only
force on earth powerful enough to end
the superhuman war he is wrong and the
reason why is because we transition to
the united nations where a meeting is
being undertaken and you have all these
world leaders who are saying this
multi-megaton nuclear explosion held in
reserve for just this moment that he
says take a look at mankind's last hope
capable of vaporizing a country achieved
in a force field unbreachable by all
catalogued meta-human powers a
deployment system that's virtually
undetectable that essentially they've
been waiting for something like this to
happen and when this thing goes off
there will be casualties there will be
civilians who will die but the reality
and what humanity is arguing here what
this guy's presenting is he's saying
listen to me and understand there is
nothing rational about dispatching
tactical nukes into the heart of our own
country but these are not rational times
we are at the flashpoint of human
existence my god you can hear the battle
even here at any moment it threatens to
spread forth and engulf the world what
then what do we do in that circumstance
and he says the only way to ensure that
future generations remember this as
humanity's final option is to ensure
that there will be future generations
after today let us strike while we still
can god's speed and the response is the
united nations fires off these uh these
jets containing tactical nukes and so
jumping back to this major conflict
again it's all heroes fighting heroes
and even norman mckay says that he says
even in the brightest day the dust of
the battle eclipses the sun itself the
prisoners released by marvel's
thunderbolts strike out blindly wonder
woman's troops return force in kind both
sides fight with reckless abandon
whatever heroic moors of combat might
once have ruled them becomes nostalgic
memories this is not a fight that will
eventually die down this is a forest
fire that's just begun a war that may
well end the world any instant now there
will be fatalities and no way to turn
back with superman deadlocked their only
prayer of deliverance rests with a force
from on high and this is the arrival of
batman along with his entire team and he
says batman's legion soars in like a
silent cavalry man or machine each agent
knows his mission stem the loss of life
prevent the riot while there's still
time to exert control the sheer force of
batman's presence kindles a desperate
ember of hope too late right like
there's nothing that batman's presence
can do to calm everybody down he does
what he can where he can but in the end
the arrival of batman is not changing
the tide to make things even more
difficult an argument and then
eventually a fight erupts between him
and wonder woman where he tells her this
whole thing that you have this idea of
killing these meta humans you're no
different than those crazy meta humans
themselves right those fanatics the
vigilantes who just believe or who don't
really care about collateral damage
you've become the very thing that you
swore to fight against right this idea
of spreading love and understanding but
don't be afraid to bloody your knuckles
doing it he says at the end of the day
what you're what you're doing here
everything that you're doing here is not
going to win you back your position with
the amazonians you're overcompensating
and in your overcompensation you're
leading to the ending of everything that
wonder woman fires back and it's like
why in the world do you believe you have
any right to condemn me after all these
years of you just vanishing from the
entirety of the landscape we could have
used you after superman left we needed
you and you were nowhere to be found
superman abandoned us and so did you at
a time when we actually needed you the
most you could have been our liaison to
the rest of humanity our eyes and ears
you could have spoken truth to lies you
could have been this person but instead
you weren't but you cowered in your bat
cave turning your entire city into a
some kind of a dictatorship ruling it
with an iron fist who are you to tell me
the problem with operating like some
kind of a dictator after all this time
your hypocrisy still knows no bounce and
in this giant fight between the two of
them suddenly something catches batman's
attention and that's when he sees these
drones these jets flying towards their
conflict with nuclear bombs and that's
when you switch over to the fight
between superman and shazam and it's
just this really amazing fight right
because the entire time shazam is not
holding back and that's one of the big
differences between the two that in the
various conflicts they've had over the
years by whatever manner and whatever
means that billy batson was always the
moral compass right he always held back
because he was never really aiming to
kill that's not the case here right
under the mind control of lex luthor his
job is to kill superman that's his
purpose here so there's no real holding
back here that's why he keeps yelling
shazam that's why he just keeps like
just hitting superman with all this
energy and that's why superman is quite
literally dying in this fight and in a
lot of ways people see it happen but
they're so caught up with their own
battles that they actually end up
missing the fact that superman is being
killed by shazam and so switching back
to wonder woman in batman batman says
open your eyes diana right your answer
flies on metal wings those are nuclear
carriers the ultimate warbringers our
war is not one uh one act of violence at
the cost of some lies our war ends in
extinction if you're that devoted to the
amazon honor if your soul genuinely
longs for atonement on amazonian terms
then let's keep fighting and let the
planes do their work and the response of
wonder woman is no and she ultimately
stands down and the two of them end up
going after these drones the problem
here is that as norman mckay is watching
this he says despite my spectral form i
feel the heat of batman's lasers i feel
the strain of titanium muscles and i
hear the whisper of a pilot begging for
forgiveness because they missed one and
one of the bombs comes falling down to
its destination they couldn't get to it
in time and so what happens is you end
up having superman who just seizes
shazam right just grabs his mouth and
billy batson turns back into his human
form and norman mckay says for one
frozen instant the storm clears fingers
that can fuse coal into diamond crawl
across human bone and in the hush of
ears that can hear a cell divide pick
out with chilling ease the scream of
human rage a wave of x-rays confirms the
bomb's potency a telescopic glance
calculates the seconds before impact he
has to act now and that's when spectre
says it is time right judgment has come
norman mckay the hour tolls our entire
journey has brought us to this moment
and he says judge and judge wisely that
the specter needs a human host and he
puts the responsibility on norman mckay
and says you have witnessed all of this
you've seen all of this unfold norman
mckay judge who will be condemned in
this will it be humanity that will end
or will it be will it be the metahumans
that will end what will happen here and
so it's this really really just
beautiful and amazing moment because
we're told superman's palm spasms around
batson's jaw and bats and whimpers the
clock is racing only moments remain
before the blast and superman says
listen to me billy listen harder than
you have ever listened before and he
says look around us look at what we've
come to there's a bomb falling either it
kills us or we run rampant across the
globe i can still stop the bomb billy
that much i'm sure of what i don't know
is whether i should be allowed to
superhumans or mankind one will pay the
ultimate price and that decision billy
batson is not for me to make i am not a
god i am not a man but you billy you're
both and so he says more than anyone who
has ever existed you know what it's like
to live in both worlds only you can
weigh their worth equally fight the
brainwashing billy you can let me go or
with a word you can stop me do you
understand the choice that can be made
by you alone and norma mccaig chimes in
and says the tears of billy batson
answer this question for superman and
superman says then decide decide the
world and ultimately superman takes off
and in the moment when superman leaves
billy batson yells shazam and the seven
thunders come crashing down billy turns
back into shazam again grabs superman
smashes him into the ground and goes
flying up to the bomb now it's one of
these crazy moments because when this
happens everybody stops fighting like
everybody stops and they're just
watching shazam as he's racing up to
this nuclear bomb that's going to
annihilate them all he shouts shazam
three times the bomb goes off and billy
batson dies like literally he sacrifices
himself to save every superhero here and
all the specter says is judgment right
this just super iconic scene of superman
on his knees screaming if you ever saw
that shot that's where that's from it's
from kingdom come and he's just
surrounded by dead bodies that's it when
he gets up superman is eight kinds of
pissed this guy is incensed and
ultimately the specter's like i've done
my job right judgment has been has been
passed it's time for me to go he
literally bids norman mckay for a while
and norman's like no you're not going
anywhere right like you're bound to me
right like you're literally your spirit
is bound to me if only in the moment if
you really believe that letting superman
just race off and whatever happens next
is just you know it's whatever that's
what's truly evil because all i saw here
was bedlam and tragedy sadness right
just a man who made a series of bad
decisions and led everything to this if
you leave now then that really is an
evil thing and so ultimately we end up
following them to the united nations
where superman's going and this guy
starts to unleash holy hell i mean just
like starts to rip down the ceiling
right he's gonna kill everybody here
he's gonna kill every single person here
and the specter says after 10 years
superman has finally let free a wrath
that would cower satan himself how can
any man possibly calm the fury that he
feels towards his prosecutors and that's
when norman mckay steps up and he says
clark don't do this right you blame
yourself for captain marvel for magog
and kansas for 10 years that ended today
yes you're angry but in that anger
you're forgetting once more what humans
feel this is what humanity has been
feeling for a long time humanity didn't
just fire off these rockets at you to
annihilate you because you just pissed
them off one last time it's because all
they've known since your emergence the
emergence of metahumans is fear they
might follow you they might smile at you
but at the end of the day in their heart
of hearts they're scared of you because
you tower above them you fly above them
you spend your time above them they
never really see you exist in a
watchtower that literally orbits the
world right like you are always in a
state above them all they know is fear
you are an omnipresence reminder that
they are not you and how easy it would
be for you to destroy them and that's
when superman asks who are you and why
are you here and norman says listen to
me clark he says of all the things that
you can do all of your powers the
greatest has always been your
instinctive knowledge of right and wrong
it was a gift of your own humanity you
never had to question your choices in
any situation any crisis you always knew
what to do but the minute that you made
the super more important than the man
the day you decided to turn your back on
mankind that completely cost you your
instinct that took your judgment away
and he says take it back if you want
redemption clark it lies in the very
next decision that you make make it as a
man and make it right and so ultimately
when he's met by the arrival of all
these survivors he's shocked by it all
he's like how did anybody survive and
we're basically told that between the
flash and between green lantern and what
have you basically some heroes were
protected or some meta humans were
protected the big concern though is that
humanity still has the same level of
distrust like magog is among these
people who has survived right there's
still the same level of distrust the
same everything right and the question
of wonder woman is what do we do now
right like what do we do now clark it's
still the same thing like we're still
super like there's less of us but we're
still meta humans right there's still
those individuals out there who believe
that that fighting is the only way to
solve problems and to a degree that's
true right violence is not always the
answer but it is a answer and it's
usually a very effective one and the
response to superman is years ago i let
those that i swore to protect drive me
away we all did and that was the day all
of this began and and these people say
like we saw you as gods and superman
says so did we we saw ourselves as gods
too who could somehow lead you into a
better place but that's not what you
need that's not what humanity needed
humanity did not need to be a horse that
we strapped a rope to and led to water
what humanity needed was someone to show
them how to get there what you needed
was for us to live among you to be a
part of you but not to be above you and
that will change from this point going
forward we will no longer operate above
all of you we will work alongside you we
will work with you we will help you make
the world a better place we will offer
our wisdom and our guidance from our own
experiences we will bring that to the
table i can bring you wisdom and
guidance from a long dead civilization
that's that was vastly more more
advanced than yours was at the time that
it expired batman is the most
intelligent person in the world wonder
woman has the experience and wisdom of
quite literally gods
we can bring all of this to the table
and we can help make you better and
we're going to do this by also using the
wisdom of a man who left his legacy on
the world by sacrificing his life of
billy batson and they actually end up
using the cape of billy batson as one of
the flags at the united nations and so
what you get is this sort of epilogue
where you end up finding out that wayne
manor has basically been rebuilt it's
been turned into a hospital to treat
those who survived the entirety of the
soup of the meta-human conflict but
it'll also serve as basically a way to
kind of keep those detained uh lex
luthor's one of those
[Laughter]
superman of course is recovering he's
accompanied by wonder woman who's also
probably offering her own methods of
recovery for superman if you know what i
mean but you also have wonder woman
regaining her ranks among the amazonians
right having basically ushered the world
into a better place what you get in the
aftermath of this meta-human conflict is
really a utopia you get an entire utopia
here and it's a wonderful and a
beautiful thing because a lot of these
graves are built in remembrance of those
individuals who died and clark kent
actually starts working to set kansas
back to a place where it can be it can
go back to being the bread basket right
you can go back to growing crops and
different things along those lines they
lead the world into a much better place
and to a utopia that they always wanted
it to be and that right there is the
value of violence had this entire
meta-human conflict never taken place in
the in the first place would this future
ever have come to fruition would it have
ever happened and the answer is most
likely no if superman had stayed hands
off if he had remained in his fortress
and never gotten involved you likely
would have seen some kind of a nuclear
response by humanity and the world would
have just been plunged into chaos those
meta-humans who did survive would have
annihilated what remained of humanity
and they would have taken the world for
themselves and that would have been the
end of it right that what it took was a
massive conflict it took death and
destruction on that scale in order to
force the change of both humanity and
metahumans because it's only in the face
of such tragic loss that we're actually
forced to confront what caused that loss
in the first place in that moment we're
caught up we're all emotionally swept up
with everything that's going on right
that's exactly what happened here
superman wonder woman batman green
lantern the flash humanity likes luther
so on and so forth they were so caught
up in the situation that no one ever
stopped to take a step back and asked
the question how did we get here what
led us to this point it was only when
humanity were when the many humans were
facing their own extinction at the hands
of a nuclear arsenal and that near
extinction came to fruition had it not
been for billy batson if that bomb had
detonated a ground zero they all would
have been killed likely superman too i
don't know that would have been the case
but presumably it would have been maybe
you would have survived i don't know but
the thing is most the entire meta-human
population would have been destroyed
right like it was only in the face of
their own extinction and annihilation
that they were finally able to to heal
bla peel back this this cloak right this
blanket of destruction and death and
despair and come to terms with what
they'd done and the fact that superman
himself had led the hero uh the
metahuman community on this collision
course it was his actions that led
things to getting where they were and so
everything is really kind of settling
back down norman mckay finds his own
measure of hope reaffirms his conviction
in god goes back to reading the bible
and this congregation grows it's that
kind of thing this serves a greater
purpose what's really cool is like the
specter as jim corrigan shows up to
listen to his sermon at one point in
time that's the beauty of it all and so
of course for the first time in the
story you have a superman and you've got
a wonder woman who basically show up to
planet krypton where they sit down and
they basically realize everybody's
dressed up as superheroes not gonna lie
i would go to this place if this place
existed in the real world i don't know
if it does and if it does exist i will
go to wherever i need to be in order to
be able to go there but i would
absolutely go to this place 100 and in
fact you know what like if this is
something that's like a major kind of a
convention right of like they do this at
san diego comic-con we should all go
right i mean i don't know if you know
one or two point what the 2.132 million
three 130 000 people can fit in there
but uh we'll try so like i would love
[Laughter]
i would love like to go to a place like
this it just looks amazing but at the
end of the day it's really the three of
them just kind of sitting down and
having this conversation and really just
being a part of humanity not really
above them not really beyond them not
operating outside of them but basically
being among them and just kind of
enjoying their life among people having
this conversation talking about
everything that's going on right that
you know batman and having this
conversation says that it's been a long
road for rehabilitation for the for all
the injured he says fortunately i'm not
laboring alone i was able to put several
members of the mankind liberation front
to work in our ad hoc hospital and when
he says he put him to work he means like
slap collars around their necks and made
them work which rightfully they deserved
he says they're pulling their weight
vandal savage alone has picked up quite
a few healing tricks in his 50 000 years
that's really them just kind of talking
about everything that's happening having
this conversation and what's really
really cool is you end up finding out
that uh wonder woman and superman they
kind of got something going on right
that batman's a little pissed off
because the stick is well done which i
you know you know i can't even judge him
for that whatever man but you have this
moment where like wonder woman and
batman or superman are like hey we kind
of have something to share and batman's
like yeah you're pregnant i already know
like i know you're pregnant wonder woman
right so like superman knocked up wonder
woman making a life for himself that's
really what's going on here it's just
kind of going forward right they want
batman to be the godfather which i don't
know why anybody would ask that right i
would never ask batman to be the
godfather of my child ever well there
would be there would okay i'll take that
back there would be rules i would be
like he has to be a robin at least once
he has to be set up financially for the
rest of his life or her life or whatever
they have to be able to drive the
batmobile at least one time like they
have to be able to take the batmobile to
prom that's that's like a rule right
like i mean i don't know how i would
reinforce that i'd be dead if batman was
like if it came to that right i would
have been dead hence the nature of a
godfather but i'd be like you have to
let my child take the batmobile to prom
because how dope would that be you'll be
walking away with other people's prom
dates you know but nonetheless it's just
one of those things right you gotta take
you gotta have the batmobile taking the
batmobile to prom will be legit but
again kind of being more serious here
right getting back down to a serious
tone and talking about all this it
really is everything coming to a close
right that this world has achieved a
level of peace and a level of of
understanding and really a utopia that
was previously never thought possible
all it took was the near extinction of
the entirety of the metahuman race
coming from a decision that humanity
didn't want to make in order for it to
happen but with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this to an end this
was the story of kingdom come absolutely
loved it let me know what you guys think
about it and i will catch you all later
peace
you